this question is a definite integral and
we asked to evaluate this integral from
naught upon 6 for this trig function now
the reason why this looks a bit tricky
is because what we have to integrate
here isn't sort of a nice standard
function we're used to seeing we don't
know what the primitive is as a sort of
memorize the results so we have to do
some kind of play around with this to
put it into a form that we do know how
to recognize and then we can work with
them okay
now the main problem is well there's two
problems the first problem is that
you've got sine and cos as a product
right so we we usually are used to doing
with dealing with just one or the other
and the second problem is that each of
these is is squared right so we're used
to dealing with stuff if it's like you
know sine you know 3x ok we know how to
integrate that that's fine we can use
reverse chain rule because the reverse
chain rule the derivative of that inside
function is quite easy to work out
whereas for sine squared cos squared
when using your first chain rule it's a
little more complex so we're gonna have
to work with this and translate it if
you like into a problem that we are a
little more comfortable with okay so
what's the first thing we can do well I
can notice that because both of these
terms are squared right I can say it's
sine cos or squared DX okay now the
reason why that's a helpful step is
because sine x cos x i recognize as not
quite but very very close to one of the
identities I know namely that sine two x
is equal to two sine x cos x okay so
even though I don't have to assign X cos
x here I've got half of that so if I if
I move that two over to here it'll be
1/2 sine 2 X right so that's a good step
I have eliminated some of the problem
here because now I don't have the sine
in the clause I just have a single
function and that's a bit neater than
what I had before
okay so now I'm gonna just to make
things a bit simpler again that half
which is being squared so we
it's a quarter it's just a consonant so
I'm gonna pull it out the front like so
okay so this is where we're at now and
in some ways even though this is better
we're still kind of stuck because we
have the original problem that we had
naming that this stuff is squared if I
want to use reverse chain rule on this
I'd need a cos 2x flying around to be
the derivative of the inside function so
what am I gonna do here well hmm I need
to recognize some kind of identity that
were useful to me here in order to turn
this sine squared into something that's
not squared you know it's not something
like like this kind of thing where
there's no extra power it's just a an
extra coefficient on the inside function
okay so noting that we used the double
angle formula for signed from this step
to this step I can use the double angle
formula for cosine to help me out here
now how does that work well okay let's
have a look at this way remember that
cars 2x actually I'll call it 2 theta
okay as an identity as an expansion I
can expand it in a variety of ways okay
now the standard way the most common way
to expand it is as close squared theta
minus sine squared theta okay and that's
fine however there are other ways to do
it for instance using the Pythagorean
identity right I can swap out this cos
squared for a sorry this sine squared
for a 1 minus cos squared so to become
close squared theta minus in brackets 1
minus cos square theta so that double
negative is gonna mean I can write it as
2 cos squared theta minus 1 now exactly
the same way that I swapped out the sine
squared I can swap out the cos squared
using the same identity and I can say
well if that's 1 minus sine squared
minus sine squared the whole thing is 1
minus 2 sine squared okay now these are
all just different ways of writing the
same identity right all these 3 now
which of these is most useful to me well
you can see it's going to be this last
one here the third one
okay this one here because what it links
is a sine squared with close to theta
right so I can even though from here I'm
going from cos 2theta to something an
expansion I can do it the other way I
can rearrange it so if I move that one
over I'll have minus 2 theta okay and
now I can move that minus 2 over so if I
divide through by minus 1/2
that'll switch the order and we'll put a
half at the front so I get this ok so
this is really good this is now sine
squared in terms of cos 2theta
okay now this is good but I can do one
better than this because what I've got
is not a theater but it 2x right so if I
replace that theta over here with 2x
okay that'll mean that over here this is
cos 2theta
and I just said theater was 2x so this
will become cos 4x okay excellent
so now I have an identity that I can use
which will help me out to evaluate this
integral so sine squared 2x is equal to
this and that half I'll drag it at the
front again so that's gonna make it an 8
at the front not 2 pi on 6 and this is 1
minus cos 4x okay excellent
now at this point what I've put this
into a form is something that I really
can integrate this is a big improvement
from what I started with right because I
know how to integrate a constant and I
know how to integrate this there are no
more powers or extra trig functions fire
em so now I can get to the work of
actually integrating so let's do that I
still have this 1/8 at the front okay
now what's the primitive of 1 its X
what's the primitive of minus cos 4x
it'll be minus 1/4 sine 4x okay from
naught to PI on 6 okay and notice that I
have a numb I haven't made any
substitutions or anything like that I
just
been doing trig identities all the way
through that's why my boundaries haven't
changed in any way
okay so now I can evaluate now I've got
one eight at the front and then what am
I gonna have in here
well you've got your PI on six there is
your first party upper boundary then a
quarter so now for lots of pylon 6 is 4
PI and 6 which is 2 pi on 3 and then I
have to subtract the lower boundary
evaluated 0 which happens to be 0 minus
1/4 sine 0 which is also 0 so you don't
have to worry about this guy so now we
just have to evaluate here
what's 1/8 of Pi on 6 well that's PI on
48 - now what's happening here that 1/8
and that quarter will become one on 32
sine 2 pi on 3 what's sine 2 pi 3 well
let's see here that's what sign looks
like and 2 pi and 3 is somewhere out
here using symmetry you can see it's
equal to sine of pi on 3 and that's sine
60 degrees if you're thinking more in
degrees in radians and sine 60 is root 3
on 2 and I reset I can ignore these
zeros okay so there's my final answer PI
on 48 minus root 3 on 64